have you seen other performers put all
their eggs in one basket and how is that
different for you to know that you know
what I have my own show to fall back on
it doesn't matter if someone didn't pick
me I pick me for my show and I picked my
guess how does that work out for you um
yeah you know I just you know God
blessed them it seems when people put
their eggs in one basket off and it
leads to very quick big success and
monetary success but I come up with
catch phrases that they push incessantly
as punch line of most of their jokes or
you know do something like that that I
don't love I've never done that myself
and I jokingly will say like I should
have the catchphrase so I could become
really successful but when you put all
your eggs in the basket of One Show or
something that's fine I mean should
always have other projects I think going
that you're passionate about because it
should be shouldn't be about success so
if you have other things that you're
passionate about one more project and
your back burner and your pocket or your
slowly tinkering with as you do your
other thing and that's probably enough
for you I don't think you should ever
take any one show that you have as the
be all and end all of your career
because shows end as do relationships as
do friendship says do you know they
don't always end but generally they do I
meant that just really for friendships
relationships shows do always in some
point Nation ships and tears to meet the
press relationships do end at some point
somebody dies the worst that the longest
case sure or earlier well but then how
did you start the podcast like what was
I wanted to do a podcast long time
actually did a podcast you referred
anybody was really doing them I never
released it stupidly and I lost the
files and all these cool podcasts with
great comedians are now really well
known that were in my car is called glee
drives with and I was with these
different comedians on the way from LA
to irvine I lost them all have like one
or two left at released one on mice
podcast recently with Greg Proops but
then I was and done everybody start
doing podcast I wanted to do one and
then I just random ended up being like
the guest host or co-panelists on this
pilot with Kevin Smith
and and he ended up talking after the
show we got stoned after the show and
and he wanted hear my life story and I
told it to him and at the end of that
company we were missing the whole wrap
party while we were talking for an hour
and he then the conversation he said to
me so what are you you're a production
guy you're a guy that makes your own
things what are you doing being here on
a guest on my show or on chelsea's panel
aren't you gonna do your own stuff again
and it really inspired me when he said
that I already been thinking that along
those lines but I hadn't didn't have the
kick in the ass to really start doing it
and then Kevin just gave me a kick in
the ass he then said to me you got to
come up my podcast be aghast I went to
his house and and he says to me during
the first commercial break do you want
to guest host my podcast here in my
house this friday when I'm out of town I
said of course I do and then the end of
the podcast he said to me do you want
your own show my network and I said yes
I do but I'm torn between these
different podcast ideas I have a format
this interview 1 i've just title out
that one I have one right cover all the
week's news and it's called last week on
earth and he goes that name is brilliant
I never heard such a good name it's
unique podcast but I'm anything like it
that's the one you should do first and
he just was so decisive and I'm like
yeah you don't say no to Kevin Smith
telling you you should do a show and his
network and thinks your titles brilliant
I started doing it and forward as the
advice I got years ago for my first
manager is Howard Lapidus he said you'll
remember this advice one day and I did
because he said that and sent Matt my
brain remembered probably but he said
forward motion but gets forward motion
and really does just do anything if you
do anything that is something you're
interested in something that feels
productive or creative it will lead to
your next thing either by learning what
you don't want to do but more so it just
puts out in the universe this energy
that's it's an engine you can't stop it
just literally like propels like a
steamship engine that just you know
slowly starts to go and as it starts to
get more water under if this how steam
engines work I've really making that up
I don't know if they do progressively
get faster I've assume seem that gaining
steam is a phrase we've all heard that
hopefully that they're the steam
propeller does not end up running over
the front facing whale tail that somehow
progresses it under the ship on the way
out still know why we can't forget about
the way right whales always under the
water you can't walk
so yeah I remember that we wheels don't
walk hello think what I'm trying to make
all right but splash she want she has a
mermaid she was a murderer that's half
person half whale I don't know we're
talking about half people have whales
that was the case then yes the whale
could walk away from steamships because
probably very dangerous with that motion
gaining sure sure per pet what is it
called propeller I think the propellant
it's a wheel also it's a wheel maybe I
don't know how the new boats are but
yeah I wonder if the love boat had that
look if when they did is probably felt
very exciting a new to them probably
Emily so you've never had sort of a sit
on the couch moment depressed my life is
going nowhere it sounds like you're just
always doing something or what it lasted
like a nanosec yeah I've had those
moments but you end up you know either
having a drink or smoke that night and
decompressing or go and hang out with a
friend or have a minorly
self-destructive night to get it out of
your system or write something the
self-destructive ones never seemed to
help you feel great the next day you
feel generally were sore tired but every
time I felt like worthless I felt like
I'm just a piece of that doesn't do
anything anything done the cure for it
every time was when I finally got my ass
and went to a workout room and tried
some new jokes in a small stand-up room
or a big room and just got any time you
try some new jokes one of them works
every time the way would just be lifted
off my shoulders may be like oh right
the answer is to work and there's always
just to work I mean it sounds so stupid
because it's a corporate slogan but the
most succinct best slogan for success in
life I think is just do it like you
really stole that for shoe and it's
unfair because it's a great slogan and I
say it you sound like an but I'd
it's a good advice does something to do
a shoes right what does have to do a
shoes any other follow-up corporate
slogan now it's just just do it it's a
great one you've got mail no it's not
really a good life slogan now you always
have mail but that's just so slow yeah
uh but just do it I mean it's nice
nothing to the point is just nothing to
do with shoes sure just do what the shoe
so telling you have sex of your shoe
like what does it mean out of the
context of do something your life
just do it and then choose unrelated the
co-opted brilliance took it to sell
that's a lot of times what's wrong with
the country you got brilliant moments
and then what we do with that as we turn
it into selling you why can't a
brilliant moment just sit alone Billy
Joel said it leave a tender moment alone
why not let a brilliant moment linger
for a second always got to have a slogan
always these brilliantly inspiring
commercials you know the human condition
and selling your eggs or some like
it's good i'll do the eggs but here are
some human eggs if you are admitting a
be infringing commercial i would be an
apropos mixture of slogan and content
but that's rare you know never fits stay
the Holiday Inn Express recently some
ballin in my life their slogan will stay
inspired it's also a good advice they
inspires very good advice but no one's
inspire were saying at a Holiday Inn
Express it's one of the low moans it's
one of the least inspiring moments their
lives your slogan can't outshoot your
product by a mile that's just very
people aren't gonna buy it I mean maybe
idiots gonna be like oh yeah I'm
inspired here most people are gonna be
like oh I just remembered how uninspired
I am staying here there's luggage sure
there's been like we're a hotel you can
sleep here right got clean sheets know
that maybe cleanish there will be a
Danish in plastic in the morning that'll
be a fair slogan or didn't criticize
that I'd be happy with that I would not
stay there I wouldn't say that with a
better slogan either
you